- [Narrator] In Japan, restaurants,
and to be clear, I mean
a ton of restaurants,
use plastic food displays
to entice customers.
And in Gujo province,
there's a small factory
that's responsible for more than half
of all the plastic sushi, crab,
omelets, duck, ramen, beef,
oh my God, that's all plastic?
This is Satori Kaboki.
- (speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] This factory has
about 30 full-time artists
because all these plastic
foods are made by hand.
- [Takahiro] (speaks in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Takahiro is an artist here.
- (speaks in foreign language)
- [Narrator] This trend
of plastic food in Japan
has been around since the
1930s, but blew up in the ‘50s.
And it is everywhere.
However, this food, it doesn't come cheap.
- (speaks in foreign language)
- [Narrator] It takes years of
training to master this art.
- [Takahiro] (speaking
in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Quick example:
A bowl of ramen might
take three hours to make,
while a fish: many, many more.
- [Takahiro] (speaking
in foreign language)